because of these storms barreled through
New York last night you have city
leaders that were concerned about the
migrants that were living at the Floyd
Bennett Field about five miles from
James Madison High School so they said
you know what we're worried the tents
are going to collapse because of the
rain and all the winds let's move them
into James Madison High School on the
second floor into the gymnasium let's
tell the kids the students there
tomorrow which is today this morning
we're going to go remote so they
displaced 2,000 students at that school
who don't come from the best e
economically uh economic situation
you're out and we're going to move these
migrants in that's right uh the
neighborhood that they transferred uh
these migrants to is a majority uh
minority location for the most part uh
for the kids who go to Madison High
School 63% come from economically
disadvantaged homes 52% are minorities
taxpayer costs per student and this is
for every kid in New York City
look at that it costs
$45,000 for every kid in New York City
what's interesting about the decision to
go ahead and take and and you set it up
perfectly out at uh that air former
airst strip that they have placed these
tents you know rather than drive the
tents into the ground with Stakes they
can't because they're on a Runway and
they can't break the concrete so what
they did is they just use heavy stones
and things like that there was a storm
on December the 18th and apparently the
wind gusts were up to 50 mph and bolts
shook loose in the tents and the
migrants were horrified and so that is
why yesterday exactly 24 hours from
right now Brian the city said all right
we're going to move them into this
particular high school and all those
kids who go there normally will have to
study remotely it's unbelievable uh how
much these kids uh have to pay the price
not only the economically disadvantage
in a tough area they're an overcrowded
class rooms many of these kids do not
speak English even have Spanish even as
their first language it's a different
language and then on top of that they're
asked to stay home and do the zoom
learning which we know is absolutely
detrimental to advancement and then then
we find out they're going to go into the
classroom but for how many days and then
they got to clean the classroom so it's
probably the rest of the week now
according to a statement from the city
they said they had no choice the health
and safety of migrants in our care is a
top priority to be clear this relocation
is a proactive measure being taken out
of abundance of caution to ensure the
safety and well-being of individuals
working and living at the center it
makes me wonder what they're doing on
Randall's Island on those turf fields
they also can't drive spikes into those
turf fields I would hope so they I
imagine on Randall's Island a location
which is always a bit challenging it
literally is an island where those kids
going to go on top of that that was
brought up by Ronda santis last night
here's an example of a concerned New
Yorker without kids watch
I hope it's just for one night it should
that's even what one night too long it
should be uh they shouldn't have even
been to this country they should have
came here legally like everybody else
I'm I'm I'm from Israel uh it took me 16
years to get my citizen my excuse me my
green card why should they cut the line
in front of other people that that been
working really hard to get their to get
their citizenship in this country
they're already getting free uh uh New
York IDs um they're getting free shelter
free food free free clothing everything
is for free and on our taxpayers not
anybody else's so another neighbor said
uh there are 1900 people getting thrown
into my neighborhood half a block from
where I live and we don't know who they
are they're not vetted and a lot of them
have criminal records and backgrounds
and we don't even know students and
teachers they were um they don't even
know when they're going back Brian and
Steve and the students learning what
about their learning it's so disruptive
and one of the council women who's a
republican for the city said that they
should have been placed somewhere like
the park slope slope Armory my question
is out of all the places in New York
City why would they place them in a high
school and make the students suffer you
know they don't want to put them in Park
Slope it's Rich those rich people don't
want illegal immigrants in their gyms in
their houses in their complexes you put
in workingclass communities that's the
key they don't have much of a voice
that's why in Long Island they put them
in places like Brentwood who are a
workingclass community heavily Spanish
who doesn't really have a lot of
political sway but this is a major story
because there's limited resources the
city's uh in buried in debt right now
already cutting back on ction
firefighters and now additional fees for
illegals and guys they keep on coming to
the Port Authority no one's stopping
them well here's the thing you know it
could have been so much worse because
currently that the city of New York is
housing what 60,000 migrants all across
the the uh the city uh Brian you
mentioned Randall's Island according to
the New York Post this morning they
didn't take the migrants from randle's
Island because it's not prone to
flooding they were worried about the
flooding out there at Floyd benett field
but as they move the winds yeah well
they weren't it's it's the other is a is
a Runway with a lot of open space but
but here's the thing in this particular
neighborhood where they've moved all of
those migrants how many of those people
in Brooklyn voted for Joe Biden I I
would bet most of them voted for well
this is his crisis absolutely
you know what and this morning they are
Furious about what has happened they are
now motivated to think this guy doesn't
know what he's doing when it comes to
migration It's Curious there's there was
something circulating on Twitter
yesterday fellow by the name of Tom de
said that uh and this is I haven't
confirmed this but apparently he had
heard that Lee zeldon from New York has
received formal media training he's
being vetted to serve as Donald Trump's
vice president what's that would mean is
that Donald Trump is interested in
trying to flip New York State you know
from going Democrat as it has for
decades to red and an issue like this
with Lee zeldon as his vice president if
this rumor were true I can see exactly
where that's coming from that'd be
interesting it's really New York City
that causes our state to be so blue
because there are other areas in upstate
there places out on Long Island that are
that are very Republican and this is
where the migrant problem is a mess this
is Joe Biden's crisis so when you're
going to the polls just remember this is
his crisis and you didn't know much
about the crisis before probably because
you didn't live in Texas but now the
rest of the country is discovering what
his crisis looks like because many of
these migrants are moving into your
community they get free housing they get
free food uh they everything's for free
they don't pay for anything and then
when you look at what we're paying per
student to go to school in New York City
more than 45,000 a student and they're
being kicked out and someone El else is
moving in that didn't come here the
right way and I love that sound bite of
the man who said I'm from Israel it took
me more than a decade to get here we did
it the right way why do you think you
can jump the line well those migrant
kids are winding up with an education
that cost taxpayers
$45,000 per kid when you look when you
look at the Rio Grand River and we see
the the migrants coming across with the
children your heart breaks for it but
you the number of kids who wound up in
New York City Schools just remember just
see an invisible 45k on each one of
those kids there's nothing wrong with
thinking about your country first but
there's also nothing wrong with those
kids I'm watching seven-year-olds get
off a school bus go into a high school
it's a tough situation we have nothing
against those kids they're put in this
situation their parents thought it would
be a great idea to come to America we
just can't absorb it and our president
can't understand it Governor Ronda
santis knows New York story is a
national story listen to him last
night you talk about putting Americans
last you're having these kids you're
depriving these kids of inperson
Education to be able to House people
that don't have a right to be here uh to
begin with that's Joe Biden's America in
a nutshell uh so I think it's
disgraceful that that's happening so by
this has been one of Biden probably the
biggest failure just simply because he
has more control over this uh there's
certain things president may not have
direct control over he he is causing
this uh he could stop it and he's
choosing not to stop it he is absolutely
right that was taken short that by came
at a West de Mo Iowa Town Hall after the
town hall he had last night here on Fox
tonight on Fox 9 pm Eastern Time Donald
Trump's going to sit down with Brett and
marthy you're gonna want to see it it is
must SE Brian did you see the hecklers
last night when Ronda SES was up there
on Martha yeah yeah I tell you just real
quick Steve on your point with Lee
zelden uh another person is Alise stonic
from New York getting Popular by day
she's going to be on in a couple hours
right here uh word is that she's a
finalist to be running should get the
nomination ask if she's getting formal
media training because apparently that's
what Lee zeldon is well Lee doesn't need
any training man he's he's experienced
I'm just saying he's apparently getting
the getting the training I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis